y un año después cuáles son las
ganancias de las protestas
fundamentalmente creo yo que un año
después lo que vamos a tener la
posibilidad a los chilenos y chilenas
exactamente en siete días más es un
referéndum para para cambiar la
constitución no creo que el principal
hecho quisiera recordar el lector ya
justamente que está siendo seat ibe con
ese aspecto la posibilidad de encausar
esa energía agregando un proceso de
cambio constitucional que comenzará el
próximo 25 del público del plebiscito
que está convocado para preguntarle a
los chiles medicina si quiere cambiar no
su constitución bueno pero entretanto
qué es lo que pasa con la impunidad a
menos del 1 por ciento de los
carabineros que estuvieron involucrados
en hechos de violación a los derechos
humanos en las protestas han sido
traídos a la justicia porque ha sido tan
lento el gobierno chileno en este tema
lo que pasa es que el movimiento social
iniciado no estuvo el año pasado
recordemos que tuvo un quiebre
importante provocado por la pandemia
entre marzo y agosto prácticamente que
fueron el periodo más complejo a la
bandera aquí en chile no hubo una
especie de cápsula miento por lo tanto
no se pudo avanzar porque las
prioridades están en otros temas es a
partir de septiembre de 2000 sean a
reactivarse todas estas investigaciones
y están siguiendo el curso que tiene la
justicia chilena esperamos pronto del
resultado especialmente en el caso del
día duración es contratada a los
derechos humanos los daños oculares que
se produjeron en muchas víctimas y
personas efectivamente murieron como
consecuencia de este estallido social
una de las denuncias que realizan los
activistas es que faltó muchísimo más
control gubernamental y que si piñera
hubiera tenido en cita a las fuerzas del
orden pues no se hubieran dado estas
violaciones masivas porque no fueron ni
uno ni dos los casos sino muchísimos
usted qué opina
bueno hay una crisis profunda de la
policía de carabineros como se llama en
chile x que llegaría con el estallido
social recordemos que la policía está
sometida al poder civil depende del
ministerio del interior y al yo allí no
solamente en este gobierno sino que
desde retorno a la democracia una falta
de efectividad de control por parte de
citi a las policías creo que es un tema
que está un día también la discusión
bajo el mar parte
seguramente el proceso de cambio la
construcción pero está en marcha un
proceso de reforma a la policía
carabinero como consecuencia de las
situaciones flagrantes que se produjeron
los derechos humanos a partir del
estallido social